ich weiß echt nicht wie dumm wie alle
damals waren so dass es so schwer daran
zu bestehen das 27 1280 x 720 und nicht
1427 gewarnt wird umleitet votum für
burgkirchen herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video heute mache ich was ich
schon länger ich mir gemacht hat und
zwar schaue ich mir die ersten videos
von youtube an und gucken wir dies in
ihrem ersten video sofort heute haben
wir ihr habt ihr verbrechen gesehen
prominente gäste am start wirklich um
aller feind und warschau ist heute an
luca sturm waffe und sympathisch und
katja stock mittlerweile petkovic er hat
kriegen die leute einfach bewusst nicht
mehr auf das video aber ich hab ich ja
fast wie diese damals war
derzeit ist mir die fangen an mit
schumacher sein ältestes video heißt
sturm waffe aber ich glaube das ist
nicht das wohl nach leute schauen denn
wir wollen eigentlich so und
ungefilterten einfach kein berg sondern
ein let's play oder irgendwo in die
richtung das ist ein zweites video das
heißt jetzt in die hoden klopp den
schlüssel als herzlich willkommen
herzlich willkommen
sowohl glock in die city hat mir das
sind die ersten videos leute ich weiß
wer das war alles nicht für ihr alter
nicht so durchkalkuliert damals aber das
auto bei den dingen in diesem video ist
auf jeden fall vermag wunderbares spiel
im hintergrund produziert gehabt
irgendwie überhaupt gar keine geräusche
aus der summe leisen klicken ja dass du
eigentlich gar nicht hören
trotzdem ist es auf jeden fall schon mal
deutlich lauter als eigenes kommentare
eventuell nicht optimale 4999 in die
zitiert mir das gerade rausgehauen und
das ganz schön um die ja nicht die
geschichte wie was schon aufgefallen war
und jetzt begleiter dieses geklapper
hintergründe 10.000 mal lauter als seine
eigentlich stimme effizientere games
teams also er hat ihn noch nicht so
wirklich den fluss grimm kommentiert
aber was man auf jeden fall schon merkt
ist der ist schon sehr variantenreich
dafür dass die bio so alt ist das fast
vier jahre alt vom 8
juli 2013 und auch wenn's nicht so
flüssig ist also jetzt nicht so
die ganze zeit hat einfach 15 minuten
durch landmann merkels kommentar ich
schon so sehen wir wissen sturm ist sich
der rabatt halt sehr bewusst seite und
macht sich dann über sicherheit durch
dich kennt ihr vielleicht noch irgendein
youtuber setzte auch immer auf zeit
leute geben und das erste video von und
sympathisch
[Applaus]
dieser gesichtsausdruck ist schon mal
relativ bezeichnet für seinen ganzen
kanal würde ich sagen es ist ein erstes
video ok erstellt nicht vor auf dem
kanal die kinder wohl egal eröffnet und
eher putzig zehn sekunden lief er spuckt
aus und sagt heute kommt kein video das
ist schon original muss man sein
zweitältester ab dass es ein bisschen
länger 342 immerhin interview mit
youtube ergänzen sich halt irgendwie
richtig gute instock der mega mega auf
die begehrte irgendjemandem rumschreien
und waschen oder todes abgefragte welche
was ganz ehrlich man muss das fordert
dafür geben dass er es einfach geschafft
hat mit abgefuckt bei einem kanal
großzuziehen klarheit wirklich wenn er
abgesagt ist aber das ist eigentlich nur
leistung so alle youtuber das immer so
happy happy aufgedreht aufgedreht aber
erst abgefuckte sein videos und die
leute verwenden kurs geben könnte
ich frag mich gut abgesprochen ist ob
sie sich hingesetzt haben sie überlegt
ob das ganze nicht den kanal machen und
dann sich irgendwie darauf geeinigt
haben dass erst dann kann er einfach der
abgefragt ist es ist ja wirklich eine
seltenheit sage ich mal das lasse eine
video lacht es gibt videos irgendwie
exposed sascha lacht wirklich etwas
unnatürlich interfaces ein mensch lacht
aber wie gesagt ich mag ich feiere das
nicht automatisch für die idee alles
klar ich sage mal weiter mit katja es
ist einfach erfrischend man kommt auf
ihrer seite und das erste video was ein
anlacht ist einfach kein zehn arten
video ist so was kein neues auto video
oder baden in sondern einfach mal fan
hat auf mein gesicht gespritzt als
erstes video klingt sogar nach einem
richtig ordentlichen video du bist vor
zwei jahren sehr gut an okay leute macht
jetzt kurz mal die lautstärke leise ja
ich das mal nach hier wies glaube ich
wie oft man am tag rappers man eine
richtig fette sau ist wie man auf jeden
fall aufnimmt leute erstes video falls
paar von euch auch überlegen die über zu
werden okay halt einfach erzählt darauf
diesen ratschlag nehmt euer micro
kopfschutz wegklappen
ganz wichtig und dann geht einfach mit
dem mund direkt dran und schreit einfach
so laut ihr könnt in das mikro dann kann
auf jeden fall nichts mehr schiefgehen
oder dass man einfach mal mehr essen
soll ich weiß gar nicht was draußen mit
meinen freunden oder mit meinen hunden
oder mit meiner mutter oder was einzig
einfach nur spazieren war und ich gern
kommentare bekomme wie omega war mein
kantone ihr wohnt aber in den ständig
ohne passiert sowas eigentlich nicht mit
dem hund raus geht dass der opa der gang
aus der bäckerei gegenüber kommt ein
anschreit
du bist du drin ist wo warst du aus dem
echten leben halten wollte ich mal ganz
so ein video machen weil ich kenne viele
frauen die kraft aber wer hätte das
erwartet von katar kasse wünsche dass
jedem video macht wo sie was sinnvolles
transportieren möchte die komplette
weltordnung wird heute auf den kopf
gestellt was passiert als nächstes die
erde dreht sich nicht um die sonne
sondern um arbeiter den apparat ist
tatsächlich ein guter rapper und hat es
uns allen nur verheimlichen zum guten
abschluss des heutigen videos schauen
wir doch das erste video von luca an das
kommt mir schon willst ihm bekannt was
habe ich schon mal gesehen aber es ist
glaube ich ein bisschen länger her als
lassen sich das video ist wirklich alt
gibt euch das mal dazu sei noch vor fünf
jahren hoch geworden mindestens fünf
sechs jahren sowie die hart kommt oft
seiten kann man eventuell auch an den
apothekern eheleute in diesem video
zeige ich euch einfach mal wie in einer
zufällig generierten welt in minecraft
und warum ich wiedergewählt werde
junge junge hat einfach vor dem
stimmbruch nicht so eine hohe stimme
sondern ich hab's gefühl dass der
stimmbruch bei luca gemacht hatten der
auf fans gehört hast du das liest luca
hat einfach sein ganzes leben lang so
schnupfen und mit dem stimmbruch gut
dann auf einmal frei oder aber man kann
auch als mensch gewesen tatsächlich die
wäschekammer von der nase nehmen
ihr gesehen habt habe ich keinen sieger
gegeben das ist einfach aus dem grund
damit ihr nicht vorwerfen könnten zieht
genommen hatte vorher schon mal benutzer
davor schon geguckt oder diamanten sind
dabei ist egal welches das ist das kann
diese eiche hier sein das kann auch
dieses braune haut seines komplett egal
brauchen wir später in einem video
machte geht einfach unter die erde und
versucht wir machen zu finden ich
versuche erst mal ein lover ein weg über
diese lager hier zu bauen und wir
sicherlich merkt ist das hier
nachsynchronisiert das ist
nachsynchronisiert der das
nachgesprochen ansonsten als
anfängerfehler wicht auch hatte halt
oben die schwarzen balken so alles klar
leute das war's dann von diesem video
ich habe heute einfach gedacht ich habe
mal wieder videos von youtube an weil
ich so bisschen platz war von der uni
nicht wirklich wusste was ich machen
sollte einfach zur abwechslung kammer 1
freunde habe ich hier oben könnt ihr
mich abonnieren zu über links an das
video abchecken bis zum nächsten mal
darum nach oben zeigt auf jeden fall
auch und tschüss